but we begin with the flynn pardon the
retired army lieutenant general was a
central figure in the trump transition
in 2016
and his prosecution was key to years of
trouble for president trump
correspondent kristen fisher starts us
off tonight
from the white house good evening
kristen evening mike well we knew that
president trump was planning to do this
we just didn't know when
and about two hours ago he made it
official as he often does
on twitter the president said quote it
is my great honor to announce that
general michael flynn has been granted a
full
pardon congratulations to general flynn
and his wonderful family
i know you will now have a truly
fantastic thanksgiving
well flynn pleaded guilty in 2017 to
line to the fbi about his contacts with
then-russian ambassador
sergey kislyak it was one of the first
major courtroom victories for special
counsel
robert mueller but about a year ago
flynn tried to withdraw that guilty plea
his attorneys argued that he'd been
entrapped by people like fired fbi agent
peter strzok
and then this spring attorney general
bill barr tried to have the case
against flynn dismissed barr accused
rock of setting up
a perjury trap it was a charge that
strzok
at the time dismissed as ludicrous well
that request to get the case dismissed
was still pending when president trump
granted
the full pardon this afternoon now
democrats
are furious congressman adam schiff said
in response quote
donald trump has repeatedly abused the
pardon power to reward friends and
protect those who covered up for him
this time he pardons michael flynn who
lied to hide his dealings with the
russians
it's no surprise that trump would go out
as he came in crooked
to the end so today's pardon brings to
an end a years-long battle
for the retired lieutenant general he
was one of the people identified
as a potential threat way back in the
summer of 2016 when the fbi
first opened that counterintelligence
investigation into the trump campaign
which was code named
crossfire hurricane another one of those
people paul
manafort who's also talked about
potentially receiving a pardon
before the president leaves office and
so is roger stone
who was granted clemency but not a full
pardon
over the summer now while president
trump was tweeting about this part and
his legal team
has been in pennsylvania now the state
certified the election results just
yesterday but today
a judge issued an order ordering
that that certification the fulfillment
of that certification
be delayed until another hearing on
friday but pennsylvania's democratic
attorney general
says it is a done deal and he put out a
statement that reads in part quote
today's order does not impact
yesterday's appointment of electors
for joe biden mike kristen fisher
starting us off on the north lawn
kristen
many thanks let's get more on the pardon
of former national security adviser
michael flynn and reaction from the
justice department correspondent david
spunt joins us this evening good evening
david
mike good evening to you the justice
department all the way up to attorney
general bill barr
wanted the michael flynn case dropped
out it was very unique in that
instance fox news just received a
statement from a doj official not long
ago i want to read it in part it's about
this pardon
and it's separated into three different
parts it says first the department
was not consulted we were given a heads
up today
second we would have preferred to see if
judge sullivan would act
and for the matter to be resolved in
court we were confident in the
likelihood of our success in the case
number three that being said this is
obviously an appropriate use
of the president's pardoned power mike
until the pardon
this was an active case judge emmett
sullivan heard from the department of
justice and flynn's attorneys
about why they wanted to drop the case
of someone who pleaded guilty twice
to lying to the fbi sullivan was set to
rule any day now
we've heard a lot about sydney powell
from the election but she's been with
michael flynn
after he fired his first attorney
earlier this fall ms powell said in open
court to judge sullivan
she personally asked president trump not
to pardon general flynn hoping
that he would get off on his own well a
pardon it is this is a
power that the president will only have
for a few more months as he
is in office but mike what has always
made this case so unique
is the fact that you had the prosecution
and the defense on the same side
saying they want to drop this case the
department of justice said they wanted
to go through the process with the judge
but ultimately they got their wish
granted tonight this case
is now over mike fascinating
developments david spont thanks a lot